>>In the United States
now, we're talking a lot
about international competition,
internationally benchmarked
standards and so on.
And I wanted to see what is actually
happening in terms of teaching
and learning in other countries.
So I've looked at a lot of
high-achieving countries,
and it became very
clear to me right away
that the issue is not just the
standards that are written on paper.
It's the entire teaching and
learning system that is created
in high-achieving countries like
Finland and Singapore, Australia,
Canada, Hong Kong and
others, that is very different
from what we have in
the United States.
So we have a number of
international assessments,
and the one that is most
referenced is the Program
and International Student Assessment,
which goes by the name PISA.
And on PISA, the United States
scores or ranks thirty-fifth
out of the top forty
countries in math.
We rank twenty-ninth out of the
top forty countries in science.
But we typically do a little
bit better in reading.
However, we've gone down on
the international assessments
in reading each year
that it's been given.
And we've gone down on the math
and science assessments as well.
So we're losing ground.
And while we're pushing scores upward
on the state tests that we use here,
I think the reason we're
falling down on PISA is
that PISA actually addresses
higher-order thinking
and performance skills.
In high-achieving countries, they
have school-based assessments,
as well as external assessments
that are brought together
in the accountability system,
that include things like research
and inquiry, scientific
investigations, extensive writing.
Most of these countries do not
use multiple-choice testing
to any great degree;
some don't use it at all.
Kids are always having to write,
analyze, explain their views,
produce data, analyze data, both in
the classroom and on the assessments.
And so we need to point our system
at these higher-order thinking
and performance skills,
if we're really going
to be internationally competitive.
So what you see in high-achieving
countries is typically a very lean
set of standards.
In Finland, or Japan, for example,
all of the math standards can fit
in about ten pages from K-12.
They are very clear about what
needs to be taught, and when
and how it builds over time, but
they're not overly prescriptive.
By comparison, in the United States,
many states have created
good standards.
In some states the standards are
sort of a mile wide and an inch deep.
There are 300 things to cover in
each grade level, not a small number
of things to do well and deeply.
And the content coverage of large
numbers of objectives superficially,
means that we end up
reteaching the same thing over
and over again year-after-year,
because we didn't stop and do it well
and deeply at a moment in time.
So I kids study fractions in
third grade, and then again
in fourth grade and fifth grade.
Many of them don't get it.
They're back at it
in sixth and seventh,
and there are high school students
who still haven't mastered fractions.
Whereas, if we spent, as many
countries do, a quarter of a year
on a single topic,
working on it deeply,
you could then understand it
deeply enough to move forward.
And I think this accounts for the
low achievement that we see, in part,
in this country relative
to other countries.
Take a country like Finland, which
ranks first among all the OECD,
or European nations, in reading, math
and science on the PISA assessments.
What goes on there?
One thing they do is they train
their teachers extraordinarily well.
So they are getting three years
of graduate-level teacher
education before they even get
in the classroom, and they know
how to teach all kids well.
And they focus on assessments and
the teaching of deep understanding.
>> In the classrooms, the
teachers then do a lot of work
around project-based learning.
You would often, in a classroom,
see students working on a lot
of self-initiated work,
individually and in small groups.
They may be creating a
student newspaper and working
on their journalism project.
They may be designing and
conducting scientific investigations.
When they're studying what a fish
looks like, they actually will go out
and get 30 fish, and one on
each desk and dissect the fish,
and figure out how it
operates and so on.
You'll see a lot of investigation,
and inquiry in every field.
That's really their hallmark is to
create a nation of inquiring minds.
And they also believe that it's very
important for students to reflect
on what they've done, what
they've learned and be able
to improve on it themselves.
Another vivid example
would be Singapore.
There were a group of
students I saw who were trying
to development a natural skin
treatment to keep mosquitoes away
without using artificial products.
And they had developed
five different products
and evaluated them, and so on.
They know how to design
an experiment,
they know how to conduct it
to evaluate their results
to then improve on what they've done.
This is widespread.
By contrast, science is disappearing
from our American classrooms.
Under "No Child Left
Behind," with reading
and math scores driving
the accountability system,
in low-income schools, science
is barely taught at all.
And in many schools, when it's
taught, it's taught as a list
of facts to be memorized from a
textbook, and then regurgitated
on a multiple-choice test.
Not as a process of
inquiry and investigation.
Not as a way of understanding
and evaluating and learning
about the world that you
could actually take and apply
in the world outside of school.
I have been surprised in the
countries that I've studied
about the extent to which teachers
are supported with 25 hours a week
of time for planning and learning.
So that when they get in the
classroom, what they do is very,
very well thought through.
And informed by what a lot
of other teachers are doing.
>> Interestingly, most
high-achieving countries pay teachers
about equivalently to engineers.
So they're a bit better
paid than US teachers.
But it is not the pay
that draws people
into those professions
and to stay there.
When teachers are treated
professionally,
when they feel they have a lot of
opportunity to shape the curriculum,
work with their colleagues,
develop high-quality practice,
the morale is very, very high.
The US is not a single entity.
It is a very diverse group of states.
So our highest-achieving
states do as well
as the highest-achieving
nations in the world.
Our lowest-performing states do
as poorly as nations like Jordan
and Nigeria, which are very
low-performing nations.
So we can't adapt or adopt
what any nation is doing
into our different
system whole cloth.
But we can learn from the
experience of different systems,
particularly if we
think about what should
or could be done at the state level.
We're at an interesting moment here.
The states have come together
to create Common Core standards.
More than forty states have been part
of this initiative to show in reading
and math and language arts what
should be done across the grade span.
The federal government is organizing
itself to fund new assessments
that would be tied to the
Common Core standards.
And will be reauthorizing
the Elementary
and Secondary Education
Act, which has been called
"No Child Left Behind"
over recent years.
So the federal role will
be to design an assessment
and accountability approach that
is more internationally comparable.
Allows states to undertake the kinds
of curriculum and assessment work
that will allow students
to be engaged in this kind
of higher order thinking
and performance skills.
>>Teacher: Here's our
data for our '08.
This would be the first round.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.